Alonsa ramirez has been walking with a
crutch for more than 20 years he was a
young man when he lost his leg he had
the terrible misfortune to step on a
land mine near his favorite football
pitch the explosion injured him all over
we're like a Morgul mortgage it was like
getting my flesh torn off from my back
my arms high behind my leg this leg was
completely destroyed it was horrible but
the other wizard there early Alonzo
lives in a rural area but he can't work
in the fields and there's not much else
and no government support this leaves
him dependent on his family a [ __ ] camp
near Alonso's hometown many of the
rebels living here have shed their
uniforms they want to disarm and
reintegrate into society but for now
they're stuck here both sides the
government and the rebels laid mines
during the conflict the device is killed
or maimed some 11,000 people gabrielle
used to be in charge of producing and
laying mines like the one which ended
Alonzo but he won't accept blame for
what happened with gamma blue need we
tried to keep civilians from stepping on
the minds you know but we can't
guarantee it Lydia we're always on the
move and the military oppression pretty
much forces us to use these minds to
defend ourselves yeah
la reparacion minute adista puede know
so Liga praticamente aunt Tilly's alla
para poner Devon dead Gabrielle won't
apologize but he too wants change
military role calls like these should
become a thing of the past whether the
peace treaty takes effect will soon be
decided by a nationwide referendum that
will dictate whether these guerillas can
become politicians for Alonzo this
referendum will be an emotional time
after agonizing about what to do he's
decided to vote for the peace treaty
getting where do we want to rebuild our
country and so we have to forgive those
who did us harm we have to forgive them
in order to take a step forward for the
future for a better Colombia though
buzzell as it with doodle a towel on the
mir or neighborhoods like his could
benefit directly FARC rebels say they
will help to clear remaining land mines
if the peace treaty takes effect